really Cortland is coming in and I have
some questions yeah screwball is the new
film that Billy curve and of course we
know him from cocaine Cowboys and you
and all kinds of stuff
but I saw the trailer for this screwball
movie is this a 90-minute film about
Alex Rodriguez doing steroids no okay
because that's how I advertised him
before break and it's not the sexiest
son of a [ __ ] in comedy here recognized
I've never seen his eyes I'm always like
nipples thank you I just I just saw
riffraff in the lobby making me the
third most famous Floridian in the
building great rapper riff rat who's
following I saw that guy had a giant
body growing okay love that guy yeah you
know he's the greatest he is the great
he is that is what he is the great
forget Muhammad Ali that riffraff is the
greatest so this is not just because I
watched like yeah I've only seen the
preview clip of it yeah and immediately
I'm going like it's it's a guy and he
goes you know I went to Alex rod and it
was gonna be somebody and this guy says
Alex Rodriguez opens the door and he
said who Pedro it was it was the other
player that he referenced rip made a
mirror I I want whatever you gave Manny
yeah and I'm going oh boy this doesn't
look good for a rod right now and then I
want to click the link for the screening
and the poster is just a picture
favorite yeah that's not really a poster
yeah we're just exploiting him is really
the truth this guy's trying to do Shark
Tank and whatnot hey by the way don't
forget about all right spoiler alert he
did like a lot of steroids I'm just
telling you now and real like totes it
certainly hasn't kept him out of jail oh
so I mean you know that's not my mom
knows him just like he arrived she goes
you mean JLo's boyfriend I'm like yeah
that guy that's the guy yeah it's
amazing the resurgence he's had bless
his heart I mean like he was never
really loved when he played ball and now
he's like this hole then he was banging
Madonna back then to he's all cocky a
rival caucus
yes but you're right about this he
didn't have fan support when he's
playing ball but now he comes across as
a nice guy is a broadcaster and
everybody loves him but then this
screwball movie comes out it reminds
everybody oh yeah yeah that's like oh
yeah I forgot we hated because he did
all what's your movie about comment
about 90 minutes the highest-paid
baseball player of all time was
essentially brought down and well his
career ended I should say he was not
brought down his career ended over a
four thousand dollar debt between a fake
doctor coke addicted doctor and his
tanorexic steroid patient this
whistleblower who stole the medical
records from the clinic just to nail
this this fake doctor because he's upset
at the fake doctor went to the Miami New
Times with it they blew it up like
Watergate and Alex as it turns out was
just collateral damage in that hole like
Florida [ __ ] I want revenge on the
doctor absolutely and the doctor used a
ROG real name like a dope in his records
yeah well you use a code name a rod just
written Alex Rodriguez no one would have
known that's the thing is like it's like
this sort of like Elmore Leonard Cohen
brothers ask Florida [ __ ] retail you
know that's what I love about Florida is
that that [ __ ]
the it's this weird I always said that
the people they go was Florida different
than other places and I go dude growing
up I knew two dudes without tongues I
[Laughter]
love that [ __ ] craziness the Florida
House everybody's like all upset about
the election I'm like listen it went
well all over the country but a Florida
in Florida I wouldn't have a career you
know like I mean there's this famous
saying I love that says you LA is where
you go when you want to be somebody New
York is where you go when you are
somebody and Miami's where you go when
you want to be somebody else right and
it's always been a sunny place for shady
people and that's all of Florida so do
you sit there right because clearly you
love telling
about Florida clearly problem clearly
you love telling stories about sports
clearly you love telling stories about
drugs when you find this story and
you're like are you staying in Florida a
guy with buying drugs to help him with
sports and nobody's done this movie yeah
I mean this is perfect and this was
always on our radar when it first broke
in 2013 in fact Alex came to us and
invited us to a meeting in about
November of 2013 he was right in the
midst of the arbitration here and he was
taking a break and he has an office in
Coral Gables so a mutual friend hits me
up says Alex wants to meet with you he
has an office in Coral Gables so I
figure we're gonna get together on the
down low right this is gonna be like a
secret he wants to pitch us whatever so
he says he wants to meet you high noon
at he'll stones for lunch and if ever
there's a Power Lunch spot in Coral
Gables Florida it is this place and if
there's any place I'm gonna get
recognized like from the 34:30 stuff
sure it's two miles from the University
of Miami campus so we go to this meeting
this place has this open floor plan so
everybody from the street can see the
back of the kitchen and all you know and
all the way through and they take us to
Alex Rodriguez's table which is the
center of the back wall which is on an
elevated platform this back wall of
booths and we've walked right down the
middle aisle and and get delivered to
Alex and my first my icebreaker was so
who's gonna call page six you were us
sure as [ __ ] two weeks later it was in
page six and we were just like a pawn in
his game when we bud selig and what was
he pitching you like what was anything
about I'm gonna tell my side of the
story I'm gonna blow this thing wide
open um we set there for an hour hour
and a half and he just lied to us
remember that's the admit that he did
steroids too you know I mean no but he
did Oh totally didn't see my producing
partner Alfred Spellman who's a
degenerate baseball fan I'm listening to
Alex and I leave and I turned down after
you know what this he made a lot of good
points like this guy made sense he's
pretty persuasive alphago's he's totally
full of [ __ ] everything he said other
than I'm Alex
I just wanted the timing of a good joke
what is it with these athletes I'm
listening to the Aaron Hernandez podcast
I don't think he would pre record in the
bunch washing detergent oh boy that's
going all over the floor slippy slippy
slimy go Gators yeah but but what's
wrong with these guys that like I think
I feel like in this business we run into
a lot of narcissists but the level of
knob says the same thing many times just
make it about me you weren't talking
about me going out sports is [ __ ]
ungodly yeah that's that's really the
terrible message of this movie it's like
it's about the what I call the the new
core American values because the way a
major league baseball carried on you
know I mean Alex's Ennis an eccentric
millionaire but they were like eccentric
billionaires and Major League Baseball
they had this internal FBI like their
own investigations noloty inspectors one
of these guys always [ __ ] harem I
can't help he went and slept with one of
the nurses at the biogenesis thyroid
clinic one of these guys so you're not
wrong oh my god and and they went to
never have one of those t-shirts one
said FBI on it where do you think I got
my joke from from your t-shirt laughs I
get from that shirt let me tell you
something tell me I didn't have a
[ __ ] visual of Jim Norton by himself
in Daytona with an FBI Hooters shorts on
or not am i [ __ ] in my and my green
or red visor has keep the Sun in my eyes
I like that you put him in Daytona but
driving on the beach just disgusting
that's disgusting
yeah I'm a gym rat
[Laughter]
well as always is Alec psyched about the
movie why would he like we had this
unique problem because like you know
normally make a sports documentary you
interview some some athletes you
interview coaches and then you use a
bunch of game footage so all all of this
shady [ __ ] happened in like locker rooms
in hotel rooms and live nightclub in
Miami Beach nothing happened there's no
Beauty so what we realized we needed to
do recreations so we had to hire actors
to recreate these scenes and we did it
drunk history style where they lip-sync
the interview you know the interview
dialogue and the actors are all eight
years old
smart Wow facial hair and and Yankees
pinstripe uniform this breaks lab coats
and stethoscopes and but they're all
eight years old that's great we had we
had to do that yeah but is the culture
of winning hard the problem where we're
so driven to win that's actually a great
question I don't know what to do now
it's actually not a realtor that
question I'll throw a coffee on your
floor yeah now I would imagine though
the legal process in getting a film like
this made because you're taking a lot of
things getting thrown about that if it
they weren't true people would love to
sue oh sure yeah so I would imagine that
you would have to double-check
triple-check run it through 150,000 you
have good you know I'm sure we got to
you know policy is just in case but no
we were and these were wildly litigious
people involved and like I said I met
billionaires at MLB you've got a
millionaire and an Alex Rodriguez and a
lot of them acted a fool during this
whole situation Alex spent millions of
dollars hiring private investigators
paying off witnesses buying stolen he
paid off witnesses absolutely oh yes and
he tried to send what he tried to send
Tony Bosh the fake doctor to Columbia
just to lie low for a while till the
whole thing blew over and so really like
you know the message of the movie is you
know we were kids it was like be you
know honesty integrity do unto others as
you'd have done to you and now it's like
light
and steel and you win and that's like
the message of that MLB sends an a-rod
sends and here what we call them the new
American values lie cheat and steal and
get ahead so you didn't have Major
League Baseball's cooperation on this
project no we do you see Baby Bob
Manfred oh we have a baby man you Manny
Ramirez a baby Alex Rodriguez that's
great it's pretty wild and and I hope
everybody what an interesting way to do
it to them that make that makes me want
to watch it's just that little kids were
mouthing real interview oh yeah and the
story is dumb that's the thing too is
like the story is so ridiculous like
what happened here is just so absurd
that it's like it needed to be treated
with like that level of I'm sure knowing
absurdity I suppose but did anybody try
to suspect that I want to be paid to lay
low if someone sent you to Colombia to
lay low
there's hence any to Colombia to be
killed final thing that [ __ ] ray
liotta was going to go on in Goodfellas
yeah you know I need to do this thing in
Florida how do you be killed that's what
it was go way low in Colombia doing it
standing [ __ ] middie in Colombia
there's a gold watch Callie did anybody
try to stop you from making the movie
not yet but nobody's seen it yet
Saturday when people found out that it
was in production like none of the power
players none of the major league
baseball nobody was like hey buddy we
did it real real quiet you did yeah
we're but there's funny that we were
running around Miami with what to
eight-year-olds dressed like adults with
facial hair and cop uniforms and that's
Miami no every night yeah that looked
perfectly normal
that's the thing about Miami they price
their oh I FF only a Florida folks I
just made that up I want the cash on
potential potential to catch on bro
folks put that on a tank top for me for
spring break
there's gonna be the greatest summer
ever I would I would Cokie Cowboys was
so I would absolutely watch this I love
with what your the direction going thank
you ever see his movie about the date
rape at Florida Florida he just brought
their show to a screeching halt no that
wasn't [ __ ] yeah that's what it called
there was a first doc raw deal a
question of consent we went to Sundance
where that no one yeah it is you sent me
the trigger the screener I guess I did
oh [ __ ]
it is fascinating cuz people watch this
they videotape of this guy raping a girl
allegedly allegedly but people watch it
differently it's it's almost like the
brown dress blue dress like people see
it and go no that's fine and then other
people go that's rape it's amazing what
the guy in the girls say it's it's way
too comfortable
okay okay guys I would send Jim a screen
or I will do it's it's such a good
[ __ ] movie come in and tell you what
I saw 2001 screen or something can I see
it anywhere else no you can't you
literally can see it it's it's it's so
explicit nobody would release it really
the Brits showed it on television on
channel 4 in the UK
Wow us just they wouldn't know what he
wanted to show is it because you use the
footage we use the footage and we don't
censor the footage either it's important
for the audience to see I mean you could
tell you like exactly what went down
wow yeah I would love to yeah I would
love that we do not do recreations with
children in that one no we don't and no
cocaine cow bees either do all your
movies are great all your movies are
[ __ ] phenomenal how quickly what's
one is done like do you start working on
the next one or do you have multiple
things going on at the same time used to
be like when we were you know young
independent filmmakers we do one thing
at a time would take years and write do
something like cocaine cowboys and get
it out and now we we're overlapping yeah
we have like four or five six projects
going at any given time is there anyone
that you're excited about that you can
screwball yeah et what do you think that
the El Chapo trial oh I think I wanted
to go while it was in town yeah do you
know anybody get me tickets
he's in Brooklyn yeah what do you do
when they get out bird they just seeded
a journey yesterday Sirius XM and a
woman a woman cried when she was
selected the judge won't let her off
well then how about you provide her
24-hour security forever yeah III would
never want that person on the jury oh
she's crying one of the jurors was
crying when they were selected heard in
the defense that's a [ __ ] great thing
for you
El Chapo she just glare out of the whole
time and she [ __ ] not guilty they had
to they had to send one home but they're
still acting a jury right now how do I
knock it on that obvious you want to be
on the El Chapo yo soy la macchina chapo
you don't get to be friends with him now
exactly like we was jury what do you do
when you get one perspective juror
actually wanted his autograph yeah he
was dismissed 100% a hundred percent
they behead people and the government
can't protect you there's a secret jury
though my name was Albert not guilty
crazy secret jury [ __ ] is they say
they sent somebody to some bailiffs
house for a hundred thousand dollars
give us those names they don't have that
kind of money do they don't they're drug
dealers yeah that's what would scare me
is that they could legally quarter
million dollars to somebody for the
names of the jury of course they can get
to me I don't blame that woman I'd cry
too you know I would try to and openly I
would just blow kisses at him I'd smile
at him get my shadow t-shirt I would
literally have to sit me down
you cannot boo the prosecutor best way
to get off that jury would be to wear
your FBI shirt
coming up dead judge let's get this
fiasco Your Honor a question from the
jury box
is there anything less guilty than not
guilty yes yes your honor I confess I am
the one who had those hands and tongues
and heads cut off
this man had nothing today he was just
wearing a terrible blue shirt while Sean
Penn [ __ ] the woman he likes [ __ ] Sean
Penn absolutely I mean it's crazy I
would never vote guilty mob guys are one
thing this is a different level of
barbarism it's crazy to think that I
would I mean they kill people terribly
does the drug community like you because
of cocaine Cowboys and all that it's
weird how you know we made this movie
cocaine Cowboys about this this crazy
time in in Miami history and it's become
sort of this part of like pop culture
and the historical discussion and now
it's just like I don't know we seem to
have made like folk heroes yeah I have a
bunch of the guys in the movies and the
woman in the movie and it's a little
surreal for me but but yeah I mean like
there's a lot of people I remember we
knew we made it when there was a few
years after the movie came out there was
a drug bust I think it was in Brooklyn
actually and big big organization they
tore up and they busted one of the stash
houses and in the DVD player was a
bootleg of cocaine Cowboys that these
guys were sitting and watching and and
it sort of took on that that Scarface
sort of mantle of like this this harish
Horatio Alger story the American Dream
by any means necessary isn't that
amazing that like yes it all goes wrong
like every movie like it all in the end
oh wait it all goes wrong but they
ignore that part just the beginning part
it's great like look out like we're
living like this they don't did the
ignoring part is oh they're telling us
exactly why we shouldn't do no no yeah
you have a some comics watch Chris
Farley and John Belushi and go yeah but
not me right
those guys are super successful same
thing with athletes I mean they think
they're gonna play forever the average
NFL careers are three points
years we did a documentary called broke
about athletes going right yeah and like
and you meet these guys they have like
this Superman syndrome that like no man
I'm gonna play in the NFL for 20 years
like how that's not physically doesn't
be accessible you're like money like
they're gonna keep getting big contracts
that's crazy yeah doesn't make any sense
you're Alex Rodriguez and you're like
I'm just gonna do a ton of steroids and
what does anybody need to do make a
movie about it and they totally expose
me I mean the iron is so thick you can
cut it with a knife actually say that
stuff that bird meat you say if I
thought I was just quoting in the line
of fire to quote that film didn't
correlate is there ever an appropriate
time to it to quote in the line of fire
okay Rudolph's pulling off her Secret
Service clothes and [ __ ] Clint
Eastwood hot stuff
I love John Malkovich in that right by
Clint Eastwood playing the piano [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] personality traits like
tinnitus in a car ride movie I'm still
obsessed with El Chapo juries oh my god
there would be a guy going there go you
don't know who I'll chop oh is that all
he's like no should I we'll keep this
one no how they found them they seeded
them yesterday I think yeah it's
official and they have their their
alternates in the night one of their
names believe me watch me we'll find out
oh yes you know and his brothers will
find out too much [ __ ] money yep
too much money it's gonna go on for
three or four months this trial what the
hell at least these people and their
jobs and their work like what what are
you gonna do for three or four months
yeah somebody didn't show up for work
for three months and they're not
pregnant like oh yeah chapo jury that's
who that guy is it come on it's in
Brooklyn right you know yourself don't
show up for tonight's show
the woman who cried she said she works
for some media organizations she said
well it's already came out and she said
that that people at work know or suspect
where she's where she's been during the
jury says [ __ ] that's why she was trying
that's why she was crying of every
[ __ ] like [ __ ] i jury duty this week
I can't go to work right now I got
[ __ ] jury duty hey where's bird today
jury he's got jury duty oh my oh my god
I thought it was a hat scandal at the
federal courthouse so chapeau